old former rebel great greg anthony's
son cole was drafted 15th
in tonight's nba draft one player who
didn't want the espn cameras around
apparently only wanted the channel 8
cameras around because
john treach was the only camera to get
reaction from the lone los vegan picked
in tonight's nba draft
it was an exciting night and since he
was old enough to dribble and dream
tyler bay was going to make the nba
cena's mother's struggle was grueling
getting accepted into college was
grinding
but he was not to be denied one of the
millions of kids who played basketball
only 60 got drafted this year
including this determined and deserving
las vegas
with the 36th pick in the 2020 nba draft
the philadelphia 76ers select tyler
bay from the university of colorado
i was ready to get that call and just
see where i was going it was really just
nerve-wracking but
i'm just glad i did what i have to do to
get here philly drafted bay on behalf of
dallas
good news tyler is already texas tough
his game was built at las vegas high
before finishing at a prep school to
help his college application
bayside with colorado and became a
two-way sensation in the pac-12
now big d is getting a guy who can play
deep better than anyone
a hustler a guy who is ready to go guy
who's just athletic you know ready to
see himself get better and improve a guy
who's ready
just ready to hoop but the defensive
stance can rest for a night
tyler bay is now in the ultra exclusive
club of las vegas
to the league so many people from vegas
just support me
and you know means a lot to me man it
just shows that you know
i hope that the youngers the young dudes
that play basketball here
they look up to me preparing for the
draft in a pandemic was unrelenting
but tyler's hard work was undefeated you
know just me going through what i went
through and since i was
growing up and just seeing my mom
struggle all that stuff man i just
fell in love with the game and you know
it brought me joy brought me happiness
and
i'm excited to see what the future has
honestly the dallas mavericks
got better
[Music]
all right that was